you c'est sérieux c'est bien maintenant
l'épisode du coup de fil six domaines a
pas de vidéo vous allez vous dire bah
c'est parce qu'il n'a pas eu le temps de
faire une vidéo pour vous n'allez pas
vous dire on va sûrement me lune mais je
la vois pas quand je sur sa chère parce
que youtube bugs et ben ça mon pote ça
porte un nom c'est le rasoir d'occam
[Musique]
l'idc pluralité has no name dessinée
nécessite at tous les new york soit par
les latins mais moi par exemple ça
signifie les multiples ne doivent pas
être utilisé sans nécessité
c'est un principe qu'on applique souvent
sans s'en rendre compte quand on veut
savoir quelque chose c'est peut-être
plus simple avec un exemple imaginons un
enfant et des besoins en verre dans une
pièce on ré ouvre la pièce est là il ya
plus que l'enfant soit l'enfance et elle
est portée à travers le temps et
l'espace au marché de noël de strasbourg
de 1974 pour vendre ses bonbons et se
faire de l'argent avant de revenir dans
la pièce soit il a mangé les bonnes la
seconde solution est moins coûteuse
intellectuellement et elles demandent
moins d'explications additionnel et du
coup c'est celle qu'on va privilégier
alors attention ça ne veut pas dire
qu'elle est forcément vrai et que
l'autre est fausse ça veut juste dire
voilà privilégie donc on va la tester en
premier par exemple et comme je disais
c'est un principe pour une crise tout en
somme il tombe mal car à fublaines en
week end et écume ans de sommeil de
steinbach et on vous donne à ce principe
lui porte le nom de guillaume d'ockham
qui est à plusieurs anglais qui
clairement à abuser de son rasoir pour
ce faire une coupe relativement badass
comme santé du stade qu'on a vus
ensemble ya quelques semaines c'est un
homme de foi qui a passé une bonne
partie de son existence à porter l'idée
que philosophie expérience ce sont deux
choses totalement différentes mais
qu'elles pouvaient cohabiter
après l'idée
vient pas de lui nécessairement comme
aristote par exemple qui avait 17 en
vain que l'on fait plusieurs jours qu'on
peut faire avec un petit nom est à même
dr house qui dans un épisode
quand tu entends des sabots pense au
cheval pas un zèbre r ce que je trouve
intéressant avec guillaume d'ockham
c'est qu'il est tombé sur ce principe
parce qu'il pensait que dans la nature
dieu laisser agir les causes physiques
sans intervenir à chaque fois genre
c'est un truc brûle c'est par le feu et
non par dieu c'est marrant de voir
comment le rasoir d'occam étudie
aujourd'hui le voilà donc là c'est mon
principe mais du coup peut l'appeler le
rasoir d'occam un petit peu barbant du
coup juste de seconde si j'ai bien
compris ton principe du coup si on
applique bas à dieu j'en ai plus besoin
du coup le monde il est beaucoup plus
simple sans lui à les eaux calmes a plus
simple salut rasoir d'occam après 9
avril à pessah rasoir d'occam même si le
nombre estimé que ça évoque via cette
idée de tailler les hypothèses on peut
aussi appeler ça le principe de
parcimonie
en gros le principe de parcimonie est un
principe consistant à expliquer un
phénomène avec un minimum de cause
impressionnant si loin ce n'est pas
seulement une hypothèse la plus simple
ceci ne pas rajouter d'hypothèses c'est
celle que l'on à son fils déjà et
surtout il faut prendre en compte tous
les éléments l'hypothèse si par exemple
je pars de la naissance de l'humanité et
que je vous donne la thèse gras sioniste
à savoir dieu a créé les hommes tout
simplement ou darwiniste à savoir que
l'être humain est un résultat de tout un
tas d'évolution à vous pourriez me dire
que le rasoir d'occam techniquement il
va nous orienter dans l'hypothèse où est
ce que l'hypothèse 1 elle induit le
postulat de existence de dieu qui n'est
pas trop un truc simple et plutôt
complexe il faut bien prendre en compte
tout ce qui induit l'hypothèse est
encore une fois il s'agit pas de dire
qu'une hypothèse est vrai il s'agit
juste de dire laquelle on voit un
privilégié ça me permet de trier les
hypothèses you want you she's the
children uk and they will we find you
say never au moins
[Musique]
hop et avoir le rasoir en tête c'est
important parce que parfois on cherche à
éviter la simplicité en 1915 il ya
alfred waggoner climatologues allemand
écrit un véritable scandale dans le
monde scientifique en expliquant que
tous les continents actuelle du monde
d'en former à la base qu'un seul alors
le mec évidemment avait des preuves
géologiques et fossiles et en plus cela
les continents ont défendu sans boîte
presque parfaitement mais les
scientifiques de l'époque ils ont rejeté
cette théorie parce qu'ils n'ont pas
trouvé ses preuves convaincantes il
trouvé ça trop simple ce que quelques
années plus tard arthur runs géologue
écossais a développé un intérêt suivante
la croûte terrestre serait constitué
d'une mosaïque de plaques rigides et
fracturée qui sont en mouvement continu
dans différentes directions de la terre
en gros c'est la tectonique des plaques
et non pas de blagues sur la tectonique
[Musique]
des plaques théorie finalement
incontestable qui nous prouve bien que
l'idée de waggener trop simple pour être
vrai était pourtant la bonne merci le
rapport de galles j'espère que coûte il
vous aura plu n'hésitez pas à le
partager ou bien l'imprimer en plusieurs
exemplaires et nous scotcher dans la rue
pour que les gens le voient c'est un
boulet au plus simple vous envoie du
love et de la peace cup
[Musique]